reject nation it's Greg Alva here and
cat Alvarado over here on the other side
one thing Greg and cat like to
occasionally check out together are some
creepy list videos those are fun it
always guarantee you're gonna feel good
when you watch one of these totally and
this is from one of my favorite channels
I know we've seen them together top five
unknowns five strange catfish situations
found on reddit with unfortunate endings
oh we know this is gonna be a blasty
blast at the same time I kind of hope
someone does because I made a true-crime
mm-hmm yeah yeah I love hearing about
stuff I've catfished so many people and
they catfished me in return I don't
think I understand what catfish number
five number five in February of 2003 a
16 year old named Mark met a young girl
through an MSN chatroom that was
dedicated to teens in their area we're
gonna eat your head off instantly even
though mark and only seen a single
blurry photo of Rachel and had the truth
that she was actually who she said she
wants if we know better now on the
couple became more and more involved
with each other
with Rachel eventually introducing mark
to her brother via the same chatroom to
be a meta after this marketed good to
meet up with Rachel multiple times but
she always found some sort of excuse to
not show up eventually
Rachel informed mark of a real-life
stalker that she'd been dealing with who
she also met in an innocent chatroom the
stalker had apparently been attempting
contact her there for quite some time
and according to the story he eventually
succeeded in kidnapping
allegedly the only way that he will let
Rachel go is if Mark agreed to perform
sexual acts in front of his webcam
worried for Rachel's safety he agreed to
do so rachel was then supposedly set
free though the worst part is this
entire kidnapping was completely staged
rachel was never in any danger and there
was no stalker and it turns out rachel
only ever asked mark to perform those
acts to fulfill her own twisted
fantasies but in one final twist the
girl's name wasn't even rachel
nationally she wasn't even a girl it was
a Grammar School student by the name of
John who was found out to have been a
pedophile this strange case gets much
more in-depth than it actually involves
a few individuals losing their lives due
to John command a mark to do so they're
just in that kind of thing I strongly
urge you to read the whole story as it's
all allegedly true it's a pretty easy
story to find so just google it why not
just title us right now this next story
comes from Reddit and the user says this
happened twice both times they were
underage but they led me to believe that
they were the same age that I was the
first time it was a girl who sent me
pictures of her older sister it was
around my age when we finally met for
our first date I realized she was not
the girl from the photos she was barely
eighteen it was nothing like the photos
she had said she was apologetic though
and explained that she sent me pictures
of her sisters never self for various
reasons the lie about her age was only a
slight problem because she ingests heard
eighteen days before so it wasn't any
legal matter we made friends for a few
years after this time was the last time
I tried to meet a girl online I was
junior in college and I've been talking
to this girl a few states away for weeks
she claimed to be 19 and I was 20
she was a cute redhead in the picture
she sent to me so I chatted around
regularly even though she lived for
that's how she surprised me with her
plan to take her bus out to my
University and spent a weekend hanging
out and party when I picked you up at
the bus stop I barely even recognized
you
she sort of looked like the cute redhead
I'd pictures of but way way younger like
she could have been the daughter of the
girl I had been talking to online
I played alcohol and I tried to be
but quickly decided that spending the
weekend partying with what appears to be
a 16 year old was probably a bad idea I
told him that there were no good parties
around and took her home to my parents
house where I figured we can play well
until Sunday and then shuffler off back
down to a bus and be rid of the jailbait
well late the next evening when we were
sitting in the living room floor
watching movies with my parents - phone
rings I answered the phone to hear a
crying woman pleading to know where her
daughter was and if she was okay that's
what it hit me I was harboring a
freaking teenage runaway I got the girl
on the phone of her mom and started
grabbing all of her stuff and plenty in
my car apparently her mom had found my
phone number on their phone bill and
traveled to my school looking for a dog
before police cars showed up to the girl
and said is that her I replied yeah take
her home and that was that luckily for
me I think this girl may have had a
history with running away from home if
they didn't ask me a single question or
anything they just took the girl luckily
so I had some explaining to do I didn't
return to school and all of my roommates
and neighbors told me that the campus
police the local police and state police
have been scouring the campus for me and
then underage - well this looks like a
good story yeah lucky me hope I got
nipple chills from that one 13 years ago
I was 18 years old
very awkward but still this figure 31
power in job I didn't go to college
though and they didn't know any way to
meet people except through the internet
I remember that I fell off C on a little
ride at 4:00 she said she was 19 and
live less than an hour's drive away from
me in Los Angeles that's really not that
so they send me pictures of herself and
she's absolutely beautiful we exchanged
phone numbers we would talk for hours on
the phone I forget everything we talked
about
we constantly connected she was smart
and amateur sexy voice and was studying
to be a doctor at UCLA we tried to meet
up a couple times but she got nervous
and shaking back
I wasn't suspicious though I mean the
internet was new for a lot of people and
was understandable that somewhat nervous
about meeting a stranger like that yeah
the less I told my realized friends
about her I introduced her to online
hangouts that I frequented
she got to know my people and she
charmed them as much as she did me they
all thought that I was so lucky one day
just to perform at a place you know that
is excited she broke down crying and was
inconsolable for a few minutes while I
tried to figure out what it set her off
she told me that she had a confession to
make
when I finally convinced her to just
tell me I'd slowed my breathing down and
was a picture of serenity ready to have
reality driven with the back of my skull
like a railroad spike turns out she
wasn't even 19 she was 14 and she wasn't
a student at UCLA she was a student out
of high school in the valley who she was
actually in a play just performing as an
elephant I don't know why I agreed to
see it I can say hello thanks for this
river of hope that she was lying and
trying to test my resolve or that she
had some hidden equality to shine do all
those things that she just dumped on to
an absolute creep her mother was there
with a black eye that her father had
given her apparently Jessie had told him
their about me it was her mother who
recognized me and invited me to sit
beside her there's something really sad
about how in the pure pathetic nature of
this whole situation
the miserable battered mother actually
thought her daughter had an admirer I
declined silently hating that I was
still a part of the still wondering why
I was even doing the lights went down
and the curtain was drawn and there she
was bounding around the stage dressed as
an elephant during intermission I stood
up and walked outside in the parking lot
I got in my car drove away
I turned my stereo off and just sat
silently listening to the road for over
and out
I never spoke to her again and I never
told any of my friends what actually
happened with her that wasn't too bad
creepy parents called dr. Sam for years
she was actually the reason Ben's
parents divorced about 12 years ago I
don't know the story of early doctor Sam
just as she claimed to be a doctor of
some time it also had some form of
cancer over the years but his dad's
doctor to see all kinds of money enough
that that was actually the reason why
they divorced in fact when those little
hands-free phone headsets came out she
got one who was on the phone with her
literally every second of the day she
would make up to her cats on the phone
and he'd be places like the grocery
store
meowing into a headset that no one can
even see visit her many times but every
time he had his ticket squared away her
cancer would come back and she need
emergency medical treatment at one point
any girl would bite her she'd have to go
to the house hey I got is a high-ranking
naval officer but he had to give
Afghanistan a few years ago he said his
capture there but dr. Sam arrived safely
but she had to put it down immediately
because the cat code wasn't happy
later on doctor we passed away from her
cancer honestly this all sounds so crazy
and I wouldn't believe a word of it if
Ben's mother hadn't confirmed at all my
friend's dad lost his marriage and
honestly is sandy all over a woman who
likely never even existed
oh wow that's a movie right there yeah
there we go
it's better be creepy she's active girls
watch the genie in a chat room on gay
comm she came on strong and actually
showed a lot of interest in me even
though I didn't really have much
interest in her because he's gay no I
actually started to like her and think
we may have actually hit it off if we
met
soon we started talking and texting
pretty much 24/7
she told me about how she couldn't date
anyone because her dad was a marine
engineer and builds multimillion-dollar
yachts for famous people I don't know we
believe it at first but she started
mailing me all these really expensive
things like clothes flowers gift cards
and stuff like that in order to
quote proven even though I told her that
I didn't want these items or need that
prove the good thing is she would never
tell me her last name it would be very
weird well where photos I found out that
I could do daily pull up her dad's yacht
business and I could see how rich they
really were she said she wanted to make
sure that I was with her for her and not
just for the money even though she was
the one who kept sending me gifts even
though I never asked her to you
she also said she was a head hair
stylist that Toni & Guy it made about
seven hundred dollars a day in tips
anyway one of the gifts she sent me had
a receipt in it that had her last name
on it I googled it and nothing even came
up I searched for her name with the word
yachts and still nothing at this point
things started to seem weird so I called
the Tholian guys she claimed to work out
and asked if I could schedule with her
no one there weren't there with that
name I waited a couple days and then I
informed her that one of the receipts
came with her name on it and explained
that I couldn't find her or her family
anywhere online when I told her this she
absolutely freaked out said it was crazy
and said she's going to stop talking to
him because she had cancer she hung up
on me and disconnected her phone number
within minutes it was all so weird and I
don't even know what the point of this
catfish was I'm the one who got away
with a bunch of stuff what what order
was that in because I feel like number
five was like five again I had murk
perform sexual acts in front of the
camera for him so she released from the
kidnappers
oh okay so yeah the mark was the guy who
could perform sexual acts from the
cameras where she could be released from
the kidnapping and it was really not
even a girl but I knew that because if
it wasn't girl she could have just been
like hey perform sex acts in front of
the camera for me like okay or she could
have just gone on chatroulette oh man
crazy yeah a guy you know I know a lot
of youtubers I don't know a lot of
youtubers I think of a few youtubers who
have done that thing where it's like in
all forms of entertainment where some
girl will hit them up on social media
and then they'll follow through and meet
with them and stuff there are girls who
have hit me up being like send me a
picture I'll send you a pic now I'm at a
point where I'm like gotta be careful of
that [ __ ] I had somebody on Facebook who
would hit me up and be like come on send
me pic send me pics of me and I I looked
at his Facebook and didn't quite have
enough friends like it only had like 70
French and I'm like hey that's when you
know yeah and and like he only had 70
friends and I'm like none of his
facebook pictures like had closed up off
his face
he sent me like a few like dick pics
right and he sent me if you take Ben
cool whatever I didn't really pay
attention but later on like he
disappeared and then like he came back
and was like hello again
it was super sketchy so I talked to my
buddy who's like part-time private
investigator and I'm like to see if this
guy is real I gave him the first and
last name and the guy looked him up and
I also sent my friend the dick pics okay
and there's a way there is a way to do
an image a reverse image search to see
if they're on the internet they weren't
taken they were tumblr penises oh my
gosh damn so it was just some creepy guy
I played that well really glad I never
sent him nudes yeah my stories of why I
just sent all my photos I have like
photos on the reserve and my phone just
ready to go I'm single yeah then I lost
much away and got a girlfriend so no no
this photos are accurate as they would
no it's not oh yeah oh I've done that on
online dating I usually send photos of
my brother yeah yeah or my sister
I've never done that that is a creepy
thing to do what did you feel flattered
though you have a sister just sister
what if your sister was like you know
this guy online is really cute but I
don't feel like confident of myself I've
no idea what your sister looks like so
I'm not playing insults or whatever
before she she thought it'd be like a
whole be better if I sent a photo you
cat that way you know he might want to
meet me because he just reminds you so
much my sister did that uh-huh
I would be like a sweetheart I'm going
to take you to a doctor well late the
next evening while we were sitting in
the living room floor watching movies
with my parents the phone rings well
this story's is freaking weird of me
because he said how she looked a lot
younger than the photos so I took her to
my parents home to hang out I don't know
any family that would just let their son
bring some random young girl over take
it with them over the weekend and this
poor guy had to get interrogated at
school there's so many rumors spread
about him being some creep oh yeah 100%
I don't understand his mom being like
why did you like why didn't she ask
questions like from the gate who is this
girl
why is she here and when he answered why
didn't she go let's immediately call her
family well the more response his
parents should have easily kid to oh man
that's just some bad parenting right
there dude kids are bad at adulting like
that's true but just some random girl
who lets some random girl stay with you
over the weekend creepy ass parents
about the parents were into it and the
mom what a [ __ ] the mom of the the the
catfisher because she was like I just
you didn't ask him any questions but
then [ __ ] sends police at the school
be a man no I take his side I always
take the man's yeah we can agree on that
the number three guy the one who goes to
the play convinced and the mom fights
him to sit first off I like this guy's
story because he talks like a poet way
too dramatic about the way you're
describing everything and the creepy
part about it was this girl's parent
the people who are catfishing it seems
like their parents are a little creepy
to the mama invites him to sit next to
her at the play she had a black eye from
being beat by the husband what was that
family
yikes I mean for a mom to be like yay
there's a man thinking there's my
daughter Wow he's 20 inches that's the
kind of mom you're gonna grow up to be
just as long as your daughter's getting
attention see if my theory is my
daughter is gonna be a total [ __ ] that's
like how I'm gonna roll my son he's
gonna be good is gonna keeping in his
pants he's in a wait till marriage right
not getting a girl pregnant I didn't see
that but I think he's gonna take after
you but my daughter is gonna be a total
[ __ ] bang every guy she meets that's
the way I want to raise it in Reverse so
if my son has sex with someone I'm gonna
be like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
but if my daughter has sex high fives
all around
[Laughter]
I'm gonna call my son unknown and my
girl will be called Britney Britney
Tiffany work this dr. Sam story this is
the most pathetic story I've ever heard
in my life this guy had a family and he
got obsessed with some woman who might
not even might not even exist and just
talk with her than ever he made I bought
a ticket she would say her cancers back
but what did he do he like said his cat
they said his cat to sleep what what the
[ __ ] is going on in this story it's
weird what a sad sad guy man it's weird
when men get desperate what the heck was
up with his family why didn't his wife
go let's go to counseling no I'm sure
she did I'm sure she didn't and it
didn't work
maybe I mean he was a naval Marine
officer or something like that maybe he
had some like PTSD thing and it was
transferring over to escaping with this
false relationship I don't know like the
fantasy of a relationship that they
would never have though how do you have
a relationship where you like never meet
two like
grocery store for your family okay so
much [ __ ] listen I don't even do
anything but he talked with this person
right like it was an actual girl he
would talk to her right maybe he's just
some young spoiled girl who just sent
him some gifts high five Brittany and
Tiffany album you know it sounds like
it's probably someone who's pretty young
yeah came with sure and like a little
bit not all there yeah and she was just
one of this attention from this dude
that she thought was cute this guy was a
good detective though saw receipt saw
name decided call some people special
needs
oh why would you assume that that
doesn't make this video fun sorry no I
mean person I'm just saying like they
were like extra super nice beyond the
signals of like what's problems cuz she
freaked out and blamed she gaslighted
but he still wins because it's like
catfish is like people who need help
like I said if my sister did that like
sent my I would take her to a doctor
I once got catfished kind of I once I
was on Craigslist and Craigslist this
person hit me up and send me a photo
evidently a woman right black woman she
said she want to lick me from head to
toe let's say you guys a story I was a
message for me I was like damn this
girl's cute so I went to meet up with
her really dark setting it's like she
doesn't really look like a photo but
she's still still cute
she literally looked me from head to toe
it was amazing and then she put a condom
on me sat on me was her skirt on and
that's when I realized my wing and
ding-a-ling was not in a vagina hole
then I reached down and felt it
to be continued what degree do next
after that people tell you in a later
video there's actually really
traumatized that happened because it
wasn't it was a trans person it was the
fact that you were taken by surprise
yes they didn't disclose it that was
that was the part of it yeah it's kind
of like a consent and agency exactly
that's so much yeah they're no issue
with that tell you guys the rest of the
story sometime soon subscribe to the
real rejects people thank you to top
five unknowns for making this video
click that notification bell follow Kat
Alvarado
on three social medias the three that
people use that is Twitter and Instagram
Kat Alvarado uh-huh and Facebook at Kat
have a rato comedy where she posts nudes
on there all the time that's why we
can't be friends on Facebook